es la primera vez que una guerra se ve
en vivo desde chiquito que la red social
china que fue lanzada en 2016 es
especialmente popular entre los jóvenes
y los ucranianos no han dejado de
compartir vídeos durante la guerra la
aparición de texto y el despliegue de
todas las herramientas de 'tik tok' en
este conflicto bélico lo que nos permite
ver es una
vida cotidiana con muchísimo detalle
vemos los refugios vemos las formas de
cocinar que no vemos que habitualmente
lo recibíamos mediante documentales que
ocurrían mucho tiempo después de las
guerras o de los conflictos algunos
llaman a valeria la ana frank de tick
tock esta joven ucraniana comparte su
día a día con vídeos desde su refugio
antibombas y siempre con humor explica
cómo hace cafés en electricidad o como
su mamá cocina también juntos
detalladamente cómo huyó de kiev para
llegar a polonia los jóvenes siguen al
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
gracias a la plataforma es lo que
descubrió este jueves cuando visitó a
katia una ucraniana de 16 años en un
hospital de kiev no es fácil pero
hacemos lo correcto
todo el mundo le sigue en tick tock
entonces ya hemos ocupado tick tock que
todo el mundo habla de usted todo es
sobre usted una red que hay que manejar
con cuidado para no compartir
informaciones falsas y tener en mente
que lo que se comparte es una versión
específica de la historia ninguna red
social ninguna plataforma ningún
dispositivo puede ser neutral no lo es
porque se aplican cuestiones de censura
no lo es porque se aplican patrones de
que se publique que no se publica al
contrario que en rusia donde los jóvenes
ya no pueden documentar su vida a través
de tick tock la plataforma prohibió la
publicación de nuevos vídeos desde que
se estableció la ley que penaliza
cualquier información que el gobierno
considere falso